and it's just part of it but that me out
yeah
Kalen how did you book the role of Alex
and anonymous oh how did I booked the
role of that like semi let me see it
wasn't a very glamorous story I I was
sent the audition by my agents and I
went in to do it and then they decided
that that I did an okay job so they cast
me in it
yeah it wasn't didn't require too much
effort on my part beyond learning the
lines was it a big casting call or were
you seen individually it was seen
individually yeah it's pretty pretty
standard based on my experience here in
LA you know of the family if I'd done
this yeah I think I've done like 70
auditions this year maybe slightly less
but they're all usually pretty similar
you know there's bringing one
individually right so then a lot of them
are typical in that there's not a lot of
people around or or that there are a lot
of other actors you mean people watching
me in there or the amount of actors
waiting in the waiting room yeah the
other actor yeah usually there's quite a
few people waiting for most including
like two or three is the average and
then every now and again you'll walk
into a hallway and there'll be some 20
20 guys hanging about for different
roles and things but yeah this this time
was pretty pretty regular a couple of
guys a couple of girls for different
roles just waiting to go in yeah okay um
we've talked to actors that have said
that they just devour a script they'll
read it like 20 times over and over
again I think I've heard you say that
you you maybe just read it a few times
and you like to be more spontaneous feel
like even a few times is far from the
mark for me when I go in for the
audition I usually haven't read the
script just because I don't know it's
probably like an ego thing I'm always
like Kylie enough they probably won't
cost me anyway so why should I read
their script but honestly it's just
because I'm kind of lazy but these days
I've gotten better at it I will read the
script before I go in but certainly when
I'm when I'm casting something I'll read
it through a couple times beforehand but
I like to I also like to discuss it with
the other actors a little bit and see
what their take of it is but yeah I
don't I don't read it too many times
because I don't want it to be stale for
me you know it's like if every I don't
know if you covered
had to write anything I've always been
trying to write things my whole life but
I usually leave it too long and so I've
read through the thing so many times and
I've read it so many times that I lose
interested at myself so for for a script
I've you know five times maybe five or
six times but until rap
any more than that and I think I'll get
bored of it well what are you writing
that's interesting what am i right with
you well I mean I've always wanted to
write a novel I've always wanted to just
have like hold that brick of a novel in
my hand as an accomplishment you know
but I guess right now I'm trying to
write a novel about a couple of
screenplays and the works they'll never
be finished the novel might be finished
though I'm almost done with that so
we'll see if I can't if I can't really
something published something under my
name Oh interesting yeah I've always
been interested in writing I love
reading as well and my dads are an
author so certainly I think that's work
again what is the day like for you on
set when you're working on a character
especially if you want to keep it
spontaneous you want to feel the dynamic
of the other actors uh I guess I'll wake
up as close as I possibly can to when I
have to be picked up just so that I you
know because I'm lazy like that as I
said and then I will think actually held
on so that my day just my regular day on
set right do you prefer because I know
some people prefer to be alone and I get
that because maybe they're picking up on
too much stimuli and they want to just
focus on what they have to do or some
people like to feel the room and be out
there hmm we'll see the my thing is just
so far as now the the greatest leap
character-wise that I've had to
accomplish is putting on an American
accent just because that's the farthest
from me that any one of my characters
has been I haven't yet had to play
anyone with a very specific and
documented mental handicap or some
quirky trait or something like that so
the the level of study that I've but
I've had to submit myself to has not
required that much of me of the day so I
get up and I go to a set and I'll just
have fun joke around with everyone on
set until they say alright we're about
to film and then I look at my lines and
I'll know what to do because it's you
know it's there for me it's written I
have a pretty spontaneous approach to it
again
yeah well it works I mean for your role
as Alex I know you played a Canadian but
I would not have thought you were
Australian from listening to Alex speak
so you do an incredibly convincing job
how do you do that in which advice to
other actors that are non-us natives
Oh God learn learn an American accent
just do it because there's so many
Australians I know come over and I'll
talk to them and I'll show you oh if you
got your American accent down and
they'll say oh no no but I'm you know
I'll get to that eventually and I feel
like almost before you should even
arrange any papers or before you should
even book a flight or just consider well
would you be a twinkle in your eye the
idea of living here moving here you
should have an American accent down I
feel like but yeah it was really natural
I don't deserve any credit for it if it
is if it is convincing I've been ever
six years I ought to have it down by now
but I think I had pretty much down when
I first moved here because in Australia
and I've made the joke before but I
honestly think it's because I grew up
like slightly racist you know and it
slightly racist Australian environment
you know because we make fun of everyone
at zero and so I was growing up doing
Indian Scottish Irish American accents
I'm pretty sure my first word in an
American accent was cheeseburger if it
gives you any idea of what I'm getting
at say yeah I think it was always there
and then I just I had to professionalize
it if you catch my drift well it's
interesting because from an outsider's
perspective I see that Hollywood loves
Aussies they love people from the UK and
they love people from Australia have you
seen that have you have you seen how
we're so fascinated by you or is that
different because you're looking at it
different set of eyes
I suppose you always want to find a
struggle of some kind like you know you
want a difficulty to identify with so
you you know deserve extra credit for
anything you do so I always maintain
that the novelty for Australians has
worn off just because you know I'm in
the industry now and I'd like to think
that it's not because of that but
certainly there is there's always been
this strange obsession with with the
Australian I don't know if the if it's
the accent or the the ideal Aussie that
we project you know we've we shove out
on Australia just so everyone thinks
that but I have tried to keep up the
stereotype that Australia is very
dangerous
you know you know because everyone's
always saying oh there's all these
animals it'll kill you and Australians
are really manly and that sort of thing
and so I've tried to mate try to
maintain that whenever someone asks me
do koalas kill people I say yes of
course they drop their trees vicious
vicious violent animals I think you've
said before that you are picky about the
roles that you take on and I've heard
other actors say this too what are some
of your maybe you have a mental
checklist of what you will say okay - or
maybe some red flags in terms of scripts
or roles or how you feel about a
character there's nothing there's no
real red flags beyond some look the
quality or the perceived quality I
perceived I'd like to have you know be
it religiously inclined or however you
say that I don't know that that would
stop me from doing something if I
thought it read well enough and if it
was decent you know but yeah I'm pretty
easy in that sense you know being a
working actor in Los Angeles I got to
pay my rent so honestly if it comes
through and it's not the worst thing
I've ever seen I'll probably entertain
the idea of doing it because you always
meet interesting people and certainly
always learn something even if the
character you're playing is is empty and
shallow and and you can't identify with
it at all you'll have an experience
onset that'll be worthwhile or just will
be working with someone new you'll make
a friend so there's so many facets to it
that I feel like I'm not really out of
position to be super picky with stuff
you know I'm not being offered things
left and right and crazy huge
productions I still go to auditions
every every time I need to book
something so you know I take what come
what comes around and if it's good then
great and if it's not then yeah
something something will happen anyway
well it's interesting how just being out
there and working even if it's
supposedly a free job or scale or
whatever begets other work it's it's
just it's when you stop going out it
seems like things definitely grind to a
halt I don't know if you have a younger
brother or sister but if you'd okay well
let me just okay all right so am i I
know how that is
but if you did let's say there's a
hypothetical mini version
of you what would you advise to them if
they said you know what I want to move
from Australia or wherever I'm going to
college and come to LA what would be
your sort of like okay here's what you
need to do I suppose if I were to advise
my youngest self I would have said don't
start so early really yeah even though I
got really lucky like though the only
reason that I'm still in the industries
that came over the right time when I did
the right audition and I when I booked
it and Rob Ryan I was very kind to cast
me I would say become a better person or
better human you know a more evolved
version of yourself before you come and
start doing interviews and talking to
people and and and I suppose in making
yourself known I would have liked to
have started now because I'm now I'm
quite comfortable with who I am and I
think part of who I am is born of this
industry now having been here for six
years and done so much traveling while
I've been here
that might not be Who I am now should I
have not come early but as I am now I'd
say to myself don't come early go finish
school you know because I wanted to be I
wanted to be either a physicist or a
cytologist I got me a marine biologist
and someone who studies whales I would
have loved to have done that even if I
could just swim with a whale I would
have been content and then come and been
an actor in in America I don't know yeah
I feel like I feel like I was still too
much a kid I didn't really know who I
was or what I was doing and I wish I'd
never spoken to anyone out here while I
was that young you know some of your
acting goals coming up I mean I I know
you said you you're still doing sort of
the audition grind which i think is
fascinating for us to to see as an
outsider that that you're still in it
just like that is this surprising to
hear but what are some of your acting
goals I I suppose if I if I had to
isolate some I'd want to do I want to
play Gandalf and the Lord of the Rings
if they remake it in like 4050 years if
I could pull that off
other than that and I'm more serious
attainable so a sense of what I want to
do I love period pieces I love dressing
up and you know putting myself in
different world
so I think the less contemporary the
more creative project is that the more
I'll enjoy the idea of doing it so yeah
be it set in a different time period or
different a different world that's the
stuff that I find most compelling as an
actor because it's the stuff you're not
the most fun with you dress up and you
put on an accent and you you get to go
see new places and I guess I just want
to travel to New Zealand honestly and
put on a wizard costume but yeah there
you go so you've been in LA six years
and I think I've seen you say that you
don't necessarily go out a lot in LA
which i think is surprising to think
that someone that's young handsome has
all this opportunity stays inside what
are you writing are you looking for what
shows I want to Dungeness yeah eating
cereal in your pajamas with no
fortunately and I don't go that don't
stoop that low
okay I um I don't I don't really like
I've never been a big party animal
I guess when people invite me out and
you know it's with my friends I probably
good because it seems fun I get to talk
to people that I like but I'm just as
content in my own company you know be
playing video games or reading a book or
just having a friend over that you know
and having and being able to talk them
and the calm and the quiet of my own
home or of them is more fun to me than
is going going out also I can't really
hold my liquor you know I'm not a great
drinker I'm working on it I need to be a
better Australian but yeah I've never
been a big party guy yeah
miss Ola maybe it's not quite my city I
think I'd be better off in the country
somewhere but still this is where the
work is for me
right well I've seen that be the
downfall of many people so actually I
think that living on country no no not
the party the LA party scene so maybe in
some sense that's actually a benefit um
but I think that's an only child thing
too and I think that's great yeah it
could be how you develop maybe some of
these characters and and and the ability
to do accents I think it's also partly
because I came here as I said younger
and that actually might affect my
previous answer where I said I'd rather
come here have come here later it might
be a party animal
had I stayed in Australia until I was an
adult because I would have been with all
my friends and we would have done the
regular thing and gone out and had had
fun to distract from studies and sort of
thing whereas having come here so young
I was work focused for the majority of
my time and the idea of going out never
occurred to me until people started
saying hey do you do you go out to drink
tea I mean where do you go
what's your place and friends would come
to LA and say what are the best clubs
were the best bars and I'd say well I
know what the best bars are because I
love to just go and sit with my friend
another beer but I certainly I couldn't
name a scene for you I couldn't name a
single scene here in LA except maybe the
abbey because some of my gay friends
took me to the abbey one time and that
was I was exciting I did have fun yeah
do you want me to wrap it up here so I
think we could end on the Abbott every
be perfect yeah